tag and gawkway wants out he's wanted
out he's
changed agents and at this point there's
nothing you can do to get a long-term
contract from the jaguars or anyone else
now
there's trade shatter that's emerging as
it relates to ngakue who has still yet
to sign his franchise tender
this went down last year with jadavian
clowney in the texans and it was
right before the start of the regular
season that clowney was traded from the
texans to the seahawks but the seahawks
ended up paying
a big chunk of his salary along with the
texans last year
the texans had to pay like seven million
to get this guy off the books right
and i don't think the jaguars are
willing to do that so the
the uh seahawks ended up giving up a
second round pick or a third round pick
it was a third round pick
and a couple of players jacob martin and
berkevius mingo
to get janaev and clowny with the texans
paying a large chunk of the salary
with that third round pick and look
janae and clowney
all due respect to yannick and gawkway a
healthy genevieve and clowny
is at a higher level or two than in
gawkway and
look at how that went down and this talk
of a trade
folks it's not easy to accomplish at
this point in large part because the
team that gets
yannick and gawkway cannot sign him to a
long-term contract until after the
regular season
and if you don't sign a long-term
contract you got to give him a 20
raise over this year's franchise tag to
squat on him next year when the salary
cap may only be 175 million
it's just not an attractive deal unless
the jaguars are basically giving them
away chris
yeah no i it's not you know they're
they're you're in a tough spot
because you know the times we've seen
the you know
franchise tag you know do that make a
deal and trade we saw dee
clark you know d ford frank clark we saw
that happening you know
last offseason right but those were
especially d
ford it happened early on in the off
season i mean i want to say i believe he
was franchise tagged and then like a
week later
was traded to the san francisco 49ers
and then frank clark i believe was a
little bit
after that but that was still in a time
where teams were still
trying to formulate their rosters and
all that now this was a different off
season because of covid and everything
like that and i think people were tight
with the money
and not sure what to do or how to play
this whole thing out and what was going
to happen
so that time you know came and went and
now here we are
you're right to where it's too late you
know and i pose to you before we start
the show i said could they rescind the
franchise tag
in any way but but that wouldn't make
sense either
because i would figure that would
probably be what you would do but then
he would be a free agent too so then he
could sign with anybody so i guess you
can't do that
but yeah they're stuck here and like you
know i see people online too mike i mean
i think your point is amazing and i do
think people forget
i forgot about it a little bit to a
degree like oh yeah damn if you trade
for them
you can't have them to a long-term deal
that's very risky
that totally kills his trade value like
totally kills it
to where yes you said it he's not you
deviant clowny
and i would think unless jacksonville
wants to pony up
paying some of that money there's no way
they're gonna get anything
better than a third round pick at the
very best
right that's the way at least i look at
it because i think that deal last year
what we saw
will be something you know as far as a
bar that's set with this type of
situation
19.316 million is the salary that you
inherit for yannick and gawkway this
year
and with no ability to sign him to a
long-term contract
what you are looking at after the season
is a long-term deal
with a starting point of 23.18 million
in a year where the salary cap may be
175 million
so it's a one-year rental of yannick and
gawkway
with that said what are you giving up
for a one-year 19.316 million dollar
rental of yannick and gawkway
i don't think you're giving up a
second-round pick chris and that's the
no
the selection that's been thrown around
out there no you're not
if all the seahawks did was give up a
three right
and they didn't even have to pay the
full salary they paid half the salary
right
right so if you're paying the 19.3
uh you're you're giving up well i don't
look it becomes
it becomes something so low that the
jaguars have might not do it do it yeah
if they and if they rescind the tender
here's the thing yeah remember when the
panthers rescinded the
josh josh norman right they did it
just before that window where you you
still get a compensatory draft pick if a
guy leaves as a free agency
that's the downside for the jaguars yeah
at this point if they rescind that
tender
and and i may have to go back and
confirm this but again the fact that the
panthers did it when they did it suggest
that there is that that deadline does
apply to the franchise tag
that if you rescind it now and he signed
somewhere else you don't get a
compensatory pick next year
that's a factor in this the jaguars have
shown no inclination
to trade yannick and gawkway just like
they showed no inclination to trade
jaylen ramsey but what happened they got
offered two ones and a four yeah that
changes your mind
they've never been offered anything that
would change their mind about yannick
and gawkway and i think they believe
when push comes to shove he's going to
show up and collect his 19.3 million but
chris you raise a good point
maybe they wake up one day and they say
you know what
with the pandemic no fans this year
maybe we'd rather
keep that 19.3 million maybe we'd rather
keep that cap space and roll it to next
year
maybe we don't want a guy who doesn't
want to be here and we'll just rip the
band-aid off and let him walk away and
there's still a chance that could happen
in theory i don't know that it will yeah
there's still a chance that it could
yeah no
you know and then who's going to pay and
then he's going to pay him 193 on the
open market
exactly that's exactly it too you know
and and you know right right now we're
in a spot where
yeah i don't think there's going to be a
lot of clamoring for him you know
especially for what we've said so far
you know with the whole franchise and
not being able to sign them to a
long-term deal
but again most teams yeah i'm sure
there's interest but most teams are kind
of set so
i think you know he is a guy that's it's
going to take a team to look at their
roster here over the next 10 days and go
damn we really need to do
something about our defensive ends or
whatever that may be
you know and and i don't know where that
goes listen i look at a team just to
throw a team at like seattle
i still look at them and go i don't know
why i just feel like they're going to
get involved in this conversation and
maybe try to pull off like a
deviant clowny type deal again and just
go the hell with it
maybe we do it you know i've heard the
raider's name involved in yannick and
gawkway talk
but nothing like substantial enough to
to think oh
it's getting close or anything like that
but you know after that
i don't know where he ends up and uh
it's going to be interesting to see how
it plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports